I feel like I'm Tom Cruise's love interest
standing next to you on camera you know what I
can't help my heightened genetics Gregory what is
going on there citizens of the reject Nation Greg
and Coy here today we just got out of watching
The Flash movie I want to give a special thank
you right off the bat to Christian harloff
because Coy and I individually we struggle
to get into early screenings we have sent so many
emails left and right text messages phone calls
and the only one who was able to help us out was
Christian harloff we were able to get our names
on a list unfortunately neither coin or myself
could bring a plus one that's why there's no
John today you got us right now and uh so if you
guys can go ahead and leave a like at any minute
now we might get kicked out of here I'm pretty
confident that I we saw someone make a phone
call for viewers on the edge we're gonna have to
make this really fast like The Flash and speaking
like the flash quick promo for our new shirt
right here that verse of all the Batman here
shopzeroedition.com it's one of my new faves
one of the great ways to support the channel
and one of the great ways to make yourself look
good at yourself anywho guys there's a lot that
happened in this film so real quick recap of what
happens in this movie based off of the trailer so
to make sure we're not spoiling anything for you
guys Barry Allen AKA The Flash decides to take a
trip back in time to save his dear Mother from her
untimely demise but little as you know his heroic
act lands him in an alternate reality where there
are no meta humans to be found a fear not dear
friends for Barry teams up with his younger self
the season Batman played by Michael Keaton in the
super powered Supergirl to save the day together
they must stop the notorious man of steel events
from wreaking havoc on this world and find a way
to get buried back to his own universe so much
is happening will they succeed and was this movie
good I think we should work this review a little
backwards today sometimes I'd like to you know
talk about the story first and all that themes
whatever blah blah blah let's talk about what we
really want to talk about how what'd you think
of Michael Keaton I mean everybody was waiting
for he's on the shirt you know what I'm gonna
own something Michael Keaton's not the Batman I
grew up with because my parents are really young
and I was young so it's not like our household
movie like a lot of families I like the timber
Michael Keaton movies but I don't love them
with the same reverence and this movie made
me like the more I actually like really got a
lot of moments out of the Michael Keaton Batman
I didn't expect to like land as well really
enjoyed it you could tell Michael Keaton is
having a lot of fun with this role he is just
relaxed fun Michael Keaton in this movie and
there's some Batman action that you see teased in
the trailer where you're like wow he's doing way
more [__] than you saw him do in any of those
Tim Burton movies and there are some pretty cool
fight scenes that he gets here and it was a blast
to see Michael Keating while we're on the subject
matter Keaton I gotta say there's also a lot of
DC love letters in here so if you're a Die Hard
DC fan there's a lot in here that I'm not going
to say because this is a non-spoiler but know that
there is a lot of like oh my God I can't believe
excitement Beyond Keaton uh the Keaton is the one
that's in the trailers but there's so many like
oh my God that said I love Supergirl and I have
been very vocal about my excitement for Supergirl
woman of Tomorrow the Tom King movie that is being
written by the guy that wrote the comic and I
honestly could see her in that comic now and
that was a really cool moment for me as a fan of
that run that knows it's getting adapted I really
think she could crush it she has such a strong
presence in this movie she is badass she is hot
ferocious being in this film and it did make me
go I hope moving forward in the DC Universe that
she gets to remain as Supergirl because she
is a powerful presence she's so captivating
so immediately there's not a lot of like need
to go okay she's Supergirl okay no no she's
Supergirl you immediately are endeared to her
you're immediately impressed by her just passion
and it's so apparent in every frame I'm really
that fingers crossed now we got to talk about
the person of the hour Ezra Miller I feel like
it's a obligatory thing to say for every review
I haven't heard any reviews yet I'm sure everyone
is saying something along the lines of we know of
Ezra Miller's past credences and the things
Ezra Miller has been in the spotlight for and
we kind of just gotta push that [__] to the
side for a little bit by reviewing the film
neither of us condone the actions of one Esther
Miller this movie did something that I thought
was surprisingly clever as you see in the trailer
Barry Allen time travels to the past changes some
stuff so then there's this younger Barry Allen
who has not yet become the Flash and they've had
different life experiences that younger Barry
Allen I feel like is sort of a play on the
criticisms that people have held against part of
the Annoying humorous Parts even though I actually
really enjoyed Ezra Miller's work even in the
Justice League version I enjoyed Ezra Miller's
work there are these criticisms that have been
held about Ezra Miller's character being kind of
annoying at times based off the kind of humor and
dialogue that that uh they're given pair them up
with our Barry Allen who is a much more seasoned
Flash and has all these experiences a little bit
more serious this time around so you get the
juxtaposition the duplicitousness The Duality
as Coy loves to say there's some Christians that I
have about some of the CGI in terms of using them
and some deep fake technology or whatever it is
they're doing some face swapping technology but
Ezra Miller absolutely kills it and both of these
roles fully lived in makes the scenes believable
due to their work the parts I actually loved the
most were with them and everything surrounding the
heart of this movie which was everything around
Barry Allen's personal journey I wanted to start
with the performances first because so much of
this movie I feel is elevated by the performances
what'd you think of Ezra Miller I completely
agree with everything you said I do think this
movie does some of that Marvel magic where as you
grow into a universe you can retroactively make
things work and I think Ezra Miller like you're
saying having that younger hymn that some people
critique the performance of with our Barry Allen
it shows the juxtaposition The Duality of maturity
but it also shows what it would be like to be
around yourself and I love the hero's journey
of the self-fulfilling prophecy of having to
mature and usually you don't get that in your
face and I love that this storytelling allows
him to realize the flaws in his thinking in
a way that is Visual and that is so unique to
a time travel story in Flashpoint I think the
emotionality of Ezra Miller is second to none
in this use I remember a lot of people saying
no one else could play this part I remember a
lot of people saying they were in every frame
they are and they were right about that because
there are so many amazing performances times two
for two hours it's just a Powerhouse take like if
you've seen uh Tom Hardy and legend or any number
of twin movies this is that but in a superhero
scale and at no point did I stop and go all right
there's just one of them I kept thinking that
they were them it was fun with the newer Barry
Allen because at first he is just annoying
and when I say he I understand Ezra Miller
reason he in terms of talking about Barry Allen
Barry Allen the younger version the whole point
is to make him annoying right up right away and
he was to the point where I was like I don't know
if I'll enjoy this because he's too annoying and
then he becomes very likable Ezra Miller managed
to do that thing where I was like I forgot about
all the things you did for a little while because
I was so transported by your performance oh right
yeah Michael Shannon was kind of whatever in this
which is like how do you waste Michael Shannon he
was just kind of whatever honestly and Ben Affleck
I don't know what it was I thought it was weird
I even see it seemed strange when you first see
his action scene that's teased in the trailer
it's cool but then there's parts of it where
I thought there's no way to the physicality of
the way he's being used right now and it feels
a little on the freeway that you see you know
what I mean he's been tossed around I was like
this feels too cartoony that was one of the main
thoughts I had this feels like a live action DC
animated movie which to its credit is a very
big compliment and at times makes some other
things feel a little bit strange especially when
you're used to those things being weighted yeah
that was every time something was off it was
because you're used to it from another thing
yeah so like this has the magic of shazam's joy
and the gravitas of Zack Snyder's imagery and
the Nostalgia of like a Justice League oh my God
they're Gathering but any time that you're going
from the Saturday morning cartoon but more adults
like the DC cartoons and then you throw in a Frank
Miller s Ben Affleck you're like what is happening
yeah it's like this movie clearly acknowledges the
events of Zack Snyder's Justice League but I
kind of feel like Ben afflecks was plucked out
of the Justice League one interesting because
the weight the flavor oh the kind of the when
it's just him in the suit talking and it's like
big and bright and cgi'd out I'm like something
looks really weird about this I loved him when he
was Bruce like I love he had a good brace he had
a good Brew scene yeah I talked about in our in
our trailer reaction that it felt like a splash
page and a smash of different artists all drawing
on the same page how exciting that was I think it
works in some doses but sometimes it doesn't and
I think those are the ones we're talking about for
the movie itself I think that the movie is a lot
of fun there's some great action in here I didn't
love it as much as I had hoped to love it maybe
it was a little over hyped I don't really know if
that factors in for my experience here there's
parts of this movie that I feel are a little
bit clunky for a movie called The Flash I get that
it's a fast-paced film at the same time I did feel
like this movie could kind of slow down a little
bit this movie needs a little bit of breathing
room because it kind of just keeps hopping from
plot Point like moving at such a rapid fire pace
I kind of got that thought in my head that goes
and then this happens and then this happens and
then this happens a lot of the time I did feel
like while this movie maintained a genuine sense
of fun and reverancy for films of the past not
just in terms of the DC EU but the films that
came prior you could tell there's a lot of love
from behind the camera even with the screenplay
you can tell there's so much love at the same time
there I do find that there are some strange issues
with this movie particularly in the first act a
little bit in the third act even though the third
act delivers some of the best emotional moments
this film has to offer and has some of the best
tension and Stakes this film has to offer I did
feel that this film as big of a Stakes as it is
weirdly felt like the emotionality of the stakes
was not really felt through a lot of it and there
was a lack of tension in the finale I heard a lot
of people have said that it becomes like this big
CGI Fest there's a lot of CGI but personally I
wasn't distracted by oh my God it's just becoming
another CGI battle monstrosity because it's so
consequential what ends up happening there that
it actually made up for a lot of the experience
that I was having I was like I wish there was
a little bit more stakes in this movie that were
actually felt because there are so many converging
plot lines in here I didn't really have time to
have something to worry about which I kind of felt
like was a little bit needed for me you know what
I mean you're dealing with one plot with Barry
Allen's and then now we got Batman okay now we
got Supergirl okay oh yeah the General Zod thing
that's right you know there are villains being
villains but it made up for it by being a genuine
fun ride throughout with proper fan service
I thought they executed from beginning to end
there's other things that we want to talk about
but Corey what's your like take on this movie
overall thoughts of the movie is it's I think the
strongest second act of a DC movie ever I have not
smiled that hard I have not laughed that much I
have not felt that much joy and similarly what
you were saying about the First Act it wasn't even
necessarily purely pacing for me it was that I had
to adjust to a sensibility the beginning of the
film because of the choices they have to pay off
later with the type of of clawing annoying cloying
Berry that's hard to adjust to that sense of humor
I kind of worried it would be like a slapstick
humor that would carry on and that took me a bit
to adjust you and then I realized the purpose and
it all worked out but I definitely am excited to
see it a second time because I found myself being
like oh I've heard this is the second coming of
Christ and it's not so far and then I found myself
really distracted by overthinking my experience
that's not fun in a movie I do think it is if
not the best DC EU film it's in the conversation
for top three but I definitely found myself being
aware of thinking of that which is a good sign uh
in the third act I was really invested emotionally
I was really invested in the humor I was really
invested in the action but then there were a
few moments that the CGI made me go like oh I'm
watching a movie and that's never a good feeling
so all of the pieces were there all the love was
there as he was saying the fan service is the most
deserved I think DC has done for all sorts of fans
whether you're a comic fan a TV fan a movie fan
there's so many types of fandom in DC it delivers
that but that makes the the little details that it
pulls you away from a little extra spicy like if
the CGI is off you're so go in that when it when
it pulls you out you're like oh I was it's like
there's a bigger Whiplash because of how in you
were I think one of the tricky things going into
this movie that I want other people to experience
that I wish I could have I was expecting either a
five or a one and that's not fair to any movie I
wish I'd gone in going man I'm excited to see this
movie because when I was able to be in that zone
I was in the zone I honestly want to lean into how
fun the movie is and I know that a lot of people
use that as a toss away yeah and it's kind of
exhausting because these movies are made to be fun
I didn't think about the world for two hours that
is a gift but it does it in a way that is not just
rewarding for a casual moviegoer it's rewarding
for the deep cut and when I say fun I mean I
cheered and laughed and clapped and guthawed and
the full Blockbuster experience that you want
from like a Jurassic Park or an independence
day or like the true summer Blockbusters I kept
hearing how good this was but I wasn't sure about
the summer blockbuster feeling Landing because of
how many DC movies we've had I didn't know if it
would just feel familiar and trite it doesn't it
feels original it feels bombastic it feels big and
fun which is a positive oh yeah because the movie
is clearly not just committee made you know what
I mean yeah it really feels like they still had a
vision for this film you could still feel the love
again behind what Annie mushietti was crafting
he does seem to seamlessly weave in and out of
different Aesthetics throughout this entire film
that was very impressive and especially nailing
down the emotional beats with Barry Allen and
and the story that he has with his mom in this
film that part it almost brought me to tears
uh I did not personally cry at some stuff but
I came a little close maybe because it was very
predictable from the trailer of how a lot of this
was no Flashpoint if you know Flashpoint if you
know some Flash stories it's pretty predictive
there's like a big twist that's supposed to
happen in this movie that's like the second
they introduce what the Twist on me I'm like well
it's pretty obvious what the switch could be like
you might be really surprise for you but that's
what I mean by what this movie I thought did
contextually so well was that even though
the twist was obvious the emotion behind it
everything that grounded that twist was rooted in
how does this affect Barry Allen as a person and
the consequences that Barry Allen has to deal with
the weight of choice while this movie predictable
sure it still managed to ring a lot of great drama
out of these scenes that I was not expecting to be
so wrapped up in and to have a great catharsis
with on top of that too there are some stuff
that the director himself has spoiled but there is
some big surprises in this movie that the more you
can avoid of online things that have been leaking
there's a lot of things you can spoil do not watch
TV spots because I'm worried you will have a very
color by numbers experience because this movie
has surprises that feel like they're delivering
surprises you're gonna want those there is an
action set piece that is so spectacular that even
though there were things that were very clearly
computer generated the pacing the directing the
style and the commitment is all so incredible it's
probably in my top five actions set pieces in the
DC Universe so even when the CGI is at its like
whoa there's still so much going on in a lot of
these scenes that I was like oh I'm still wrapped
up in the comic book spectacle of those scenes I
do think there's a lot of amazing action scenes in
this movie as well like I've watched a lot of The
Flash television series so to me this was like oh
this is like the Cinematic version of a lot of
the sequences they try to bring into life there
like a lot of the use of him going into the speed
forces excellent dude that opening run the opening
room was great and really getting a sense of the
distance between Flash's City and where Gotham
City is there's a lot of just amazing sequences
there with some great humor implemented throughout
but yeah I think they're they do some beautiful
sequences all around with our all the characters
we listed Supergirl Flash Batman I couldn't help
but compare some of the krytonian fights to Man
of Steel which I feel like is still top tier
level for me uh because I was like ah you know
Zack Snyder really did that [__] a little bit
better with the krytonian action but it was still
cool to see here there is some weird CGI stuff
that happens in this movie and I found it most
distracting and it's really saved by Ezra Miller's
performance because as is great throughout when
you have both of them on screen you can really
tell when they're like face planting or deep
faking I don't know what technology it is you
could tell which one is the actual one they're
filming within this take and who the other one
you know anything I only noticed that twice I
noticed it so much it was so distracting I
was very much distracted by it and they have
some great use of the speed force in here and
there was this cartoony effect that I was like
is this supposed to look cartoony because they
have a lot of these surprises and [__] but a
lot of it looks very cartoony that I struggled
with yeah there is an entire sequence that is
weighted in both spectacle and emotionality I was
able to experience the spectacle with a little
asterisk because I was like oh I'm supposed to
feel spectacle could not experience emotionality
because I was like is that a cake I could not
experience a spectacle of it because I was
distracted by this looks like a computer overall
koi would you rate it I'ma go and I'm gonna get
some spice eight points four maybe 8.5 but I gotta
think about it 8.48.5 I'm like an eight I'm like
an eight point the more the more I look back at
it the more I'm like yeah I had a lot of fun with
that so I'd probably say like an 8.3 I think I'm
gonna land on the 8.5 now that you've given your
number only because I remembered at one point
in the second act thinking that my face hurts
so bad that I needed to stop it I couldn't and I
love that feeling it's a really really fun movie
there's there's no way to there's no way to get
around that it's a super super fun movie anyway
guys fortunately did not get kicked out I have
been seeing theater attendees behind us constantly
looking at us and it keeps getting me worried so
we gotta exit out of here guys thank you so much
for being here subscribe leave a like keep a look
out for a spoiler talk we'll catch you guys soon
foreign